Alex a socially reclusive boy grappling
with loss is reluctantly attending a
summer camp not knowing how his life is
going to be altered forever there he
meets two other Misfits genjen and
initially mute adorable orphan girl from
China and Darius an outspoken boy from a
rich family during a leisurely afternoon
the trio finds themselves gathered at
the lakeside waiting to go canoeing but
as fate would have it Jen Jen with an
initially silent demeanor feels drawn to
explore the captivating Lookout Point
she had glimpsed on a camp poster Alex
curious about her whereabouts decides to
follow her into the depths of the woods
meanwhile Darius coming from a
privileged background coincidentally
finds himself nearby answering Nature's
call mistakenly assuming that he can
help Alex overcome his fear of heights
dariish devises a plan to make him
conquer his phobia by venturing close to
the edge of a cliff but just as this
precarious situation unfolds a
surprising new character named Gabriel
steps in intervening at the critical
moment in the middle of all this chaos
genjen alerted by the commotion hurries
back to reunite with the boys however
their reunion is short-lived as they
receive leave a series of alarming texts
demanding an immediate evacuation their
peaceful summer camp suddenly transforms
into a whirlwind of uncertainty and
danger as the young adventurers hastily
make their way back their hearts race as
they realize something is amiss the once
bustling Lake now stands deserted and a
bone-chilling sight awaits them alien
ships descending upon the Serene Valley
the unimaginable has become a terrifying
reality with a sense of urgency the kids
instinctively head back to the camp
seeking refuge and answers amidst the
chaos to their astonishment the
campgrounds appear eerily empty devoid
of any signs of human life except for
one person Conrad a camp counselor who
seems to have survived the mysterious
evacuation suddenly a tremendous jolt
reverberates through the air capturing
everyone's attention a dragon spacecraft
in a desperate attempt to escape the
clutches of the invading
extraterrestrial forces crashlands
nearby its impact echoing through the
valley the once astronaut inside the
spacecraft fighting for his Last Breath
entrusts Alex with a key of utmost
importance the dying astronaut explains
that this key holds the key to the
aliens destruction and must be delivered
to NASA's jet propulsion lab JPL
facility in Pasadena it is an extremely
crucial mission that has been entrusted
to the young hero tragically before the
children can fully comprehend the
gravity of their situation an alien
creature accompanied by its formidable
dog emerges ruthlessly ending the
astronaut's life things get worse and
the kids find themselves in a fight for
survival they desperately seek a place
to hide but Conrad the camp counselor
who had offered a glimmer of hope Falls
victim to the merciless aliens driven by
fear and a fierce determination to
fulfill the dying astronaut's final
request Alex and his friends muster
every ounce of courage they possess and
manage to elude the Relentless pursuit
of the Extraterrestrial Invaders
narrowly escaping from the campgrounds
in the next scene the young Heroes find
themselves at the Sheriff's Office where
an unexpected Discovery awaits them
within the confines of the cells they
encounter Lou an inmate abandoned by the
chaos unfolding outside Lou shares a
heartfelt story of his son awaiting his
return stirring a sense of empathy
within Alex moved by compassion Alex
decides to release Lou believing in the
power of redemption continuing their
Journey towards the JPL facility the
group crosses paths with a team of
Marines tasked with evacuating civilians
grateful for the key in recognizing its
significance the commander gladly
accepts it entrusting the children to
the safety of a bus hope flickers
momentarily but their respite is
short-lived as alien ships swooped down
mercilessly attacking the Convoy
claiming the lives of the Valiant
soldiers in a devastating turn of events
the dying Commander's Final Act becomes
a Beacon of Hope with unwavering
determination Alex retrieves the key
understanding its pivotal role in their
fight against the Alien Invasion
together the group rallies once more
determined to reach the JPL facility and
fulfill its Mission under the cover of
Darkness staying in Gabriel's old house
the truth behind Gabriel's troubled past
comes to light unjustly accused due to a
misunderstanding at his mother's store
where his dyscalculia had been
misconstrued Gabriel reveals himself as
an escape E from Juvenile Detention
their bonds strengthen as the weight of
their shared burdens deepens however
their path forward is still filled with
Danger a gang of masked individuals led
by the treacherous Lou emerges from the
Shadows revealing his true colors as a
murderous Thief who had deceived the
group into freeing him desperate to
possess the key for his own selfish
gains Lou demands Alex handed over Alex
refuses to surrender the key setting in
motion a harrowing Showdown the
situation escalates rapidly with Lou
brandishing a knife intent on ending
Alex's life however as it happens the
very alien that had plagued their Camp
emerges unleashing chaos upon them all
Lou and his accomplices meet their
demise consumed by the otherworldly
Force the children eventually managed to
outsmart the alien trapping it within
the confines of a backyard swimming pool
with their lives hanging in the balance
They seized this fleeting opportunity
fleeing from the clutches of danger as
the group continues their Journey
Through the dense forest things get
tense between Darius and Gabrielle In
the Heat of the Moment Darius unveils a
painful truth his father's car
dealership has crumbled leaving his
family on the verge of financial ruin
the looming threat of imprisonment hangs
over dariush's head providing insight
into the circle circumstances that led
him to the camp just as they start to
lose hope their transmitter crackles to
life broadcasting an urgent SOS message
from the doctor at JPL the very person
they were entrusted to deliver the key
to encouraged by this plea for help the
children find renewed determination to
press forward with their mission taking
refuge in a mall they seize the
opportunity to change their clothes
blending in to avoid drawing unwanted
attention with their new disguises they
spot a Ford Mustang in the parking lot
and to their surprise gen Zen reveals an
unexpected skill she knows how to drive
swiftly commandeering the vehicle they
Race Against Time to reach the JPL
facility aware that danger lurks
relentlessly behind them however their
respite is short-lived as the pursuing
alien once again threatens their escape
in the chaos they are forced to abandon
the Mustang but to their dismay they
realize they have left the key behind
determined to retrieve it dariish
bravely Ventures back risking his own
safety though he sustains injuries in
the process he manages to secure the key
and rejoin the group finally arriving at
the JPL facility their hopes are dashed
as they discover the lifeless body the
doctor realizing that his SOS message
had been a tragic result of his own
demise yet they're able to establish
radio contact with a general at NORAD
the general unveils the true
significance of the key it holds crucial
information that can be utilized to
obliterate the alien Mothership orbiting
Above This Revelation unveils a long
dormant Cold War defense project called
Excalibur now their only hope of
survival with time running out the group
Springs into action zhenjen bravely
Ventures into the basement to activate
the emergency generators only to
encounter a ferocious alien dog that
attacks her showing remarkable
resilience she manages to trap the
creature in the basement and regains her
composure returning to the command room
to assist Gabriel and the injured Darius
in inserting the keys necessary to
launch the Excalibur weapon with the
Excalibur weapon activated the ground
trembles beneath them as zhenjen Darius
and Gabriel swiftly Evacuate the JPL
building their hearts pounding with a
mix of fear and hope meanwhile Alex
takes a daring stand against the
Relentless alien luring it into an
engine test room he ingeniously
harnesses the power of the engine's
exhaust unleashing a lethal force that
vanquishes the Extraterrestrial threat
down below the trio of courageous
friends watches in awe as the sky erupts
in a spectacular display of Destruction
the alien Mothership a symbol of Terror
and impending doom is destroyed in a
brilliant burst of light vaporizing into
the atmosphere extinguishing the threat
that loomed over Humanity moments later
a heartwarming reunion takes place Alex
is joyously reunited with his mother
their Embrace filled with relief and
gratitude the children hailed as true
heroes are celebrated for their bravery
resilience and unwavering Spirit their
names become etched in the annals of
history as symbols of Hope reminding the
world of the power of unity and courage
in the face of adversity as the dust
settles in a new era Dawns Humanity
finds solace in knowing that its future
has been secured thanks to the
unwavering determination of these
extraordinary young individuals the
world rejoices in the Triumph of good
over evil as hope Reigns Supreme click
on one of the videos on your screen
right now
[Music]
thank you